brought to you by D&D beyond the
official digital toolset for the world's
greatest role-playing game play with
advantage from a studio that didn't even
make it through the 21st century comes
Hollywood's best adaptation of a manga
yet which to be fair is a really low bar
to clear Elita battle angel meet Aleta a
cyborg with the eyes of a doll the
softness of a body pillow and the heart
of a MacGuffin you have a heart strong
enough to power all of iron city for
years on the surface she's the
internet's perfect woman
a sexy killer dumpster baby who's
totally legal some 300 years old and
will kiss you if you give her chocolates
but underneath she's got a hidden
mission cram a whole franchise worth of
exposition into one short movie what's
final champion does anyone ever go to
zalem what's outside the city what holds
it up why are there so many languages
whose body is this Who am I who has the
power to do that what happened where are
those things what is that ah we don't
have time for this Aleta just go watch
Aleta it explains everything
prepare for a film said in the 2,500 s
made with the best technology of the
2010s that still plays out like it never
left the 90s where everyone is really
into X Games as scene after scene of
motor ball dominates the runtime but
always feels like a skippable minigame
in the Final Fantasy nothing says
cutting-edge future world like a roller
blade sesh with the boys
rat Duty cool but it's not all plates
babes blades babes made of blades and
blades to be there are actually some
great human actors in this movie or at
least their disembodied faces as
Jennifer Connelly spends the film being
either vaguely menacing or vaguely
helpful Maher Sheela Ali spends it as a
literal mouthpiece for someone else so
we finally meet Anita Nova and Christoph
Waltz do some heavy lifting by making
the phrase Panther Kunz sound cool
the instinctive fighting technique you
use a sponsor constant and some literal
heavy lifting by convincing the audience
he could control a giant rocket-powered
hammer well that's definitely how the
system lost her arm isn't it so gear up
for the passion project that was
supposed to be James Cameron's opus
Tilly dumb 600 pages of notes of Robert
Rodriguez and went off to make avatar
sequels instead with a final product
that blends awesome robot partying
decades-old cyberpunk tropes and
suddenly ending on a shot of Ed Wharton
instead of bringing the story to a
conclusion starring wait we're gonna do
that - oh that's frustrating story I
Robot doc hammer time he's just a skater
boy Pentium for a dream droid rage
Optimus crime hidden figure Smithers
released the saws and the first rule of
zom is you do not talk about soem Toy
Story
you know it's too bad this was the anime
James Cameron got obsessed with I mean
it's not bad but why couldn't somebody
have slipped him JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure made the wrong move you stupid
Bank that'd been awesome brought to you
by D&D beyond the official digital
toolset for the world's greatest
role-playing game play with advantage